the Joe Rogan experience but what I'm
saying is like there's just too much
[ __ ] [ __ ] about dumb [ __ ] that we
need some kind of outside [ __ ] focus
yes
something that will take us with from
outside ourselves and make us focus on
something else or legalize mushrooms
which might be um global warming but
that's that's not real right
no legalize mushrooms move to Greenland
Trump's on it no he canceled his [ __ ]
trip to Denmark because they said
they're not gonna sell em Greenland is
talking Chad now he knows what he's
doing listen chops gonna get us
Greenland good thing is like gonna cut
levy said well then it's like what could
oh yeah I can't it's bizarro world
that's all that's all people go to
Greenland to Bohan de bois ha
I think they bowhunt that that gigantic
[ __ ] furry thing what is that thing
called the musk ox a Google Greenland
musk ox ever see a musk ox you want to
know but I want to see one and then I
also want to know when I'm kidding you
invited for an elk BBQ dude come on I
mean I'm gonna I'm gonna put a kitchen
in here in this place I my plants I'll
tell you I'll come play 100 percent
success rate
I'm bowhunting angry and laying on the
muskox cuz you just walk right up to him
oh you know what it is because they they
have an instinct protect themselves
against wolves so they all huddle
together when threatened so you could
just catch them all yeah but look what
they look like brother don't even look
real they look like something out of
Star Wars those are kind of interesting
but look go to the side Jamie that some
of those other images when you see yeah
they like that perfect well you see that
walking around you like what the [ __ ] is
that
he's like a tauntaun that's insane
listen I'll lion [ __ ] duh elephant
[ __ ] a mammoth like what is that a
buffalo what is that the [ __ ] is that
thing those crazy-ass horns while looks
like a buffalo with a Tina Turner wig
and duty could be a hundred and fifty
million degrees below zero those things
just chill there's out there eating
frozen grass Hornets coming from like
their cheekbones do that crazy look in
barely looks like a real thing barely
they're beautiful and apparently he's
good the apparently it's [ __ ]
fantastic yeah that's awesome
my friend Brendan burns shot one in I
think he said he got his either in
Antarctica you get you can go to like
really really cold climates and get I
think it's like is it north northern
Canada there's somewhere in northern
Canada where you hunt them where it's
crazy like you just get on you get
pulled by by snowmobiles are you pulled
by dogs and you go like way way way the
[ __ ] out where if you break down if your
snowmobile breaks down or if your dogs
all die you are [ __ ] I mean you are so
so so so so [ __ ]
because there's nothing man there's
nothing there's the occasional polar
bear and these [ __ ] musk ox up there
and they're they don't even look like
real things and you're stumbling across
like imagine going through a whiteout
snowstorm to stumble across across this
2,000 pound enormous gigantic hairy
prehistoric beast so you could just walk
up to and shoot with a bow and arrow and
eat that's that's what's up there right
now I feel like a remnant of the past
like - the same one aside what they like
with this if they fight with those
things that because use it to [ __ ] up
other males that's what most of those
animals they're not fighting off
predators with that [ __ ] you definitely
related to breeding and all that yeah
sure they think some of it is like in
some animals depending upon how much
pressure they get from predators like
elk keep their antlers very late to keep
their antlers like into March and April
because a lot of them live around wolves
and the idea is that they need those
antlers to protect themselves from
wolves so they hold on to him longer
than deer do biology it's real crazy
yeah dude
so lucky we're so lucky we're out here
out the food chain oh my god not only
out the few chain you I can go right
down the street and get a fat steak
dinner friend you just said on the
agenda
I cannot deceive them let's do it soon
you know our spot yeah I'm sparking this
man oh you're crazy no we're dead you
living on the edge get the light don't
use a lighter yeah I'm saying oh it's
right here oh they're hot maybe you were
one of those I only use a mask and it
will play into the next tune we're gonna
do with its top yeah they come off the
top sorry I was I don't thinking the wig
oh it's like a helmet II kind of thing I
see I think they [ __ ] things up with
that that bony part in the front above
their eyebrows they keep those for life
- it's not like a deer you know good
deer loses their antlers every year
these mothers looks like a fucked-up
hairdo it does this so beautiful though
they're so beautiful like that one right
there Jamie click about a day mom live
there for church right there like above
click on that that's a beautiful
creature I mean it's so amazing that
nature can make fish they can make it's
a buffalo make that like buffalo work I
don't know man what is it bison related
ox socks
well that socks aren't they all related
bison and all that I wish I knew
[Music]
kids facts mmm was it say it's cattle
often compared to cattle now with a big
coat yeah oh it's on northern cow Wow
part of the vote bovidae family all the
species his family have two toed hooves
four chambered stomachs and are
herbivores so it's like a kind of Cal
type thing [ __ ] it's amazing aliens
mutate them nope those that's what we're
supposed to be right now well we're
supposed to be right now some sort of
stupid [ __ ] hairy dumbass has run
around getting eaten by [ __ ] but the
aliens came down and said listen let's
just plant some of our stuff in these
box
jeez and see what we can do I mean dude
when they coming back what happened man
so I'm saying when they're coming back
probably pretty soon it gotta be big
it's been brought up more and more in
the narrative and every time we go to
sleep we wake up in a new universe and I
think along those lines that uh they're
coming they're on the way right now
we're just not quite ready yet
Everlast maybe you are but some people
are not some people if the aliens were
hovering over Universal Studios their
eyes lose their minds
moving down to 101 over the Hollywood
Bowl whether it was the end or the
beginning or whatever it would be
amazing it would be very interesting if
the whole thing would go down you know I
mean if it was the end of all cool yeah
let's I mean I'm not being kind I say
hey break it off but I'm saying if
that's what it is it is or if it's the
next stage of like enlightenment and
[ __ ] you know all that goodness what
do you think people do if one of them
like hovered over every major city you
know what I think what we're talking
about is what would the majorly
religious do because I think that would
affect religious thought the most right
off top you know I mean besides the fear
of like what are they what are they here
for right the first thing was I whoa a
whole bunch of ideology goes out the
[ __ ] window right now so that would
cause a lot of panic and anxiety right
there alone you know you tell them your
your your whatever story or whatever
religion I'm not gonna go there
we're like that's not like that thing
let's put blanket it yeah you know yeah
it's gonna upset a lot of foe yeah you
know I mean right away just like oh my
god that's not what we thought existed
we're the center of everything you know
I think would happen I think people just
start [ __ ] flat earthers go out the
window right away this is over maybe
like the aliens travel here from another
debate room they have a new explanation
for it really
[Applause]